ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ครูเอ๋จะเกร็งจะเขียนวันที่หรือจะให้ครู
หญิงเขียนคะครูเอ๋เขียนเองค่ะ
โอเคค่ะแค่สกรีนนะคะ
ได้ค่ะอ้าวโอเคผู้หญิงเห็นไหมเห็นค่ะเห็น
นะคะก๋วยเขียนใหญ่ๆเลยนะฉันได้ใหญ่เลย
เหรอคะใส่ค่ะผู้หญิงวันนี้วันอะไรคะวัน
นี้วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะวันใหญ่ไหมจะได้ดีมาก
ค่ะ
วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะ x เขียนถูกไหมคะถูกค่ะครู
พี่เก๋วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
12 ค่ะวันที่ 12 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมเดือน
พฤษภาคมที่ผชเท่าไหร่คะตีผช
2565 ค่ะ
2565 ผู้หญิงมองเห็นนะคะน้องเห็นค่ะมอง
เห็นข้อ 2 ต.ค.อ๊ะ
[เพลง]
แต่ 16:00 น 51 นาที
ชายค่ะเย็นก็คือเย็นสบายหรอ
ทำไม
ทำไมครูหญิงหรอ
ผู้หญิงมองไปข้างหน้าอะข้างหน้าบ้าน
ครูหญิงเนี่ย
ไม่เย็นเลยค่ะครูเอ๋ไม่เย็นสบายมีแม่ผู้
หญิงนี่มีพระอาทิตย์อะไรค่ะมีพระอาทิตย์
ใหญ่มากๆ
อาทิตย์ใหญ่ร้อนหรอคะตอนนี้ค่ะร้อน
ที่บ้านครูเอ๋มีลม
หนู
แล้วก็มีเมฆ
อุ้ยอุ้ยลบลบอันนี้ก่อนดีกว่านะคะคุณก็
ได้ค่ะตัวเองต้องปั่น
ลบๆแป๊บลบนะคะอ่ะ
ที่บ้านครูเอ๋เนี่ยมี
มีเมฆนะคะเมฆแม่สีฟ้าๆเนอะค่ะแม่
เราก็ลงอยู่ดีๆหรือลม
หลงหมู่บ้านครูเอกก็เย็นมีเงิน
เย็น
สบาย
ดีค่ะสบายสบายนะคะออกไม่
ร้อนนะคะ
โอเคผู้หญิงคะวันนี้ไม่คุย
วันนี้อะไรคะครูเอ๋ก่อนจะคุยกันครูเอ๋จะ
ให้นักเรียนรู้จักกันเปิดการ์ด this รู้
จักอะไรอันนี้ครูเอ๋เอ๋ใช่ไหมคะอ่า
คู๋คู่่ก็จะ
เล็กๆอุ้ยไม่ใช่แต่อาจมีกูเอสวิฟคูเอมี
พี่ชาย
1 คนนะคะพี่สาว
1 คน
น้องชาย
นี้ครูเอ๋ค่ะ
เราก็มีพ่อ
แม่
ค่ะค่ะ
มีพ่อแม่ไม่มีคนพระธรรมเพราะ
มีพ่อหนึ่งคนมีแม่หนึ่งอีก 1 คู๋มีแม่สอง
คน
ทำไมครูเอ๋มีแม่สองคนว่าไปเอาแม่ก่อนคุณ
พ่อครูเอ๋มีภรรยา 2 คนหรอ
คุณพ่อมีภรรยา 1 คนอ้าวก็เนี่ยแบนแฟนนั้น
แทนภรรยาเนี่ย 1 คนแต่ว่าคุณแม่มีที่สาว
แม่มีที่สาวแล้วพ่อแม่ท้องคลอดครูเอ๋แม่
ยกครูเอ๋ให้พี่สาวก็เหมือนพี่สาวเหมือน
คุณแม่คนที่ 2 ใช่ไหมกูเองคุณแม่หนึ่งคน
ท้องแล้วก็คลอดอ่าคุณแม่อีก 1 กอร์น OO
กินอาเภอ
กินกินสองกินได้เอ๋ๆขอมีคุณแม่สองคนหนึ่ง
ไหมครูหญิงค่ะถามดี
ผู้หญิงแล้วมีคุณแม่กี่คนผู้หญิงก็มีคุณ
แม่สองคนเอาหรอโอเคคุณพ่อ
คุณแม่
ค้าแล้วก็คู่หญิงชายครูหญิง
มีพี่มีน้องไหมคะไม่มีพี่ค่ะมีน้องชาย 2
คน
มีน้องชาย
น้องชายนิดหญิงนะค่ะ
แล้วครูหญิงผู้หญิงมีคุณแม่ 2 ไปได้ยังไง
คุณพ่อแต่งงานพัทยา 1 พัทยา 2 ใช่เล็กนะ
ไม่ไม่ใช่ค่ะคุณพ่อแต่งยานภรรยา 1 คนค่ะ
แล้วทำไมมีคุณแม่ 2 คุณแม่มีน้องสาวคนแม่
มีน้องพี่สาวอา
[เพลง]
โอ้นี่เนี่ย
จริงก็ตั้งแต่ 3 ปีแล้วเห็นไหมผู้หญิง
เนี่ยอยู่กับคุณแม่ 15 ปีอยู่กับคุณแม่คน
ที่สอง
เท่าไหร่ล่ะคุย
อายุเท่าไหร่ 2  17
17 ปีเห็นไหม
7 ปี
12 หรอ 22 ปี
ของปี้
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยอยู่กับคุณแม่เนี่ยคุณแม่ที่
1 น่ะคุณแม่คุณแม่จริงๆน่ะ 15 ปี
52 เนี่ยสีเหลืองและกัน
22 ปี
ไหม
ผู้หญิงอายุเยอะจังเลยอ่ะ
เอกก็สงสัยไหมเนี่ยอีกนิดๆครูเอ๋แนะอยู่
กับคุณแม่คุณแม่จริงๆนะ 3 เดือนนะคะเออ
โอเคที่เหลือคุณแม่ที่ 2 นะคะเลยไม่บอกอิ
อิ
นับไม่ได้
คู๋แล้วทำไมครูเอ๋บอกนักเรียนว่าครูเอ๋มี
คุณพ่อมีคุณแม่มีพี่มีน้องหรอคะอ๋อก็คน
ไทยก็คุยกันเวลาเห็นว่าเอ๊ะหน้าเราใช่ไหม
คะ
หน้าเราทำไมรูปร่างใช่มั้ยมันจะเนี่ยตัว
ลงไปแขนขาเห็นถามไอ้เนี่ย
ไม่เห็น
แต่ว่าได้โอเคมัจฉาอ้าอ่า
ขาเนี่ยเหมือนใครก็ขอเหมือนคุณพ่อ
หรือเหมือนคุณแม่หรอคะอายอ่ะงั้นกูเอ๋เอา
เอารูปตรงนี้ออกก่อนเนาะค่ะ
เอาตรงนี้ออกให้เหลือคุณพ่อกับคุณแม่ก่อน
นะคะค่ะเราเอากระเพาะพ่อกับแม่
พี่น้องได้
มีพ่อ
แม่ค่ะ
พี่
พี่สาวพี่ชายครูเอ๋น้องชาย
นะคะแล้วก็พี่สาวแต่งงาน
นะคะ
พี่สาวมีสามีแล้วสามีมีลูกสาวสวย
ถูกชายมีลูกชายลูกสาวชื่อหญิงนะคะอ่ะมี
ผู้หญิงครูเอ๋ครอบครัวเดียวกันเหรอคะ
คิดว่า
ใช่ท้องนักเรียนบอกแล้วคุณแม่คนที่สองครู
หญิง
เอ๋เอ๋
และครูเอ๋วันนี้เนี่ยเราจะคุยกันว่า
เหมือนชนะเราเนี่ยครูหญิงกับครูเอ๋นะ
เหมือนพ่อเหมือนแม่ใช่ไหมคะครูเองคิดคู๋
เหมือนพ่อหรือเหมือนแม่
มีอะไรเหมือนพ่อเหมือนแม่แต่ครูหญิงอ่ะ
ต้องคิดมีอะไรเหมือนพ่อ
เหมือนแม่เหมือนคุณตาเหมือนคุณยาย
เหมือนครูเอ๋
หน้าเหมือนพ่อเหมือนแม่อ้ะเค้าจะคิดได้
เหมือนครูเอ๋มีคนมีคนพูดมากๆ
แต่เหมือนคุณตาคุณยาย
คิดว่าไม่มี
ไม่มีไม่เหมือนใช่ไหมคะ
โอเคค่ะนักเรียนครูเอ๋นะเอาคู่เอกก่อนนะ
อันที่หนึ่งอ้ะครูเอ๋เนี่ยมีนภาก่อนเลย
เหรอนี่มีอะไรเหมือนพ่อบ้าง
มีหน้าผากค่ะนะแล้วขากอันที่ 1 นะหน้าผาก
เหมือน
พ่อแน่หู
หน้าผากครูเอ๋หน้าผากพ่อเหมือนกันอันที่ 1
นะพี่อ่ะ
แต่ว่าพ่อที่นี่กู a ที่นี่โอ้เหมือนกัน
คือของเราอาจแล้วก็น่า
หน้าที่เนี้ย
พ่อ
ไม่เหมือนแม่หยังอันนี้อันที่หนึ่งนะอ่า
ของผู้หญิงนะคะผู้หญิงมีอะไรเหมือนพ่อ
ครูหญิงมีวันที่ 1 นะมีผม
ผมเหมือนพ่อโง่ใช่ๆผมอยากโศกเนี่ยนะคะ
หรือว่าผมหยิบเนี่ยเลยนะไม่อยากส่งให้
อ้อยยิ่งเลยแล้วทั้งคู่เองผมหยักศกก็เป็น
แบบนี้ค่ะสีสีผมอยากสบเข้าเป็นแบบนี้
ผมหยิกเนี่ย
นักเรียนดูนะคะว่าอันนี้คือผมผู้หญิงที่
อีกอันนี้หญิงไม่ได้ทำอะไรนะคะนักเรียนม
ถ้าเกิดออกมาก็ผมหยิกหยิกอย่างนี้เลยนะคะ
เหมือนพ่ออยากส่งในอันนี้ค่ะผู้หญิงแล้ว
เหรอคะผู้หญิงบอกนักเรียนใน 1 วีดีโอว่า
ครูหญิงผมหยักศกอันนี้อีกค่ะหยิบ
ต่างเปลี่ยนครูหญิงไงชอบเขาว่าอยากสบใช่
ค่ะเพราะมันรู้สึกผมไม่อีกแต่ว่าผมผู้
หญิงอีกนะคะใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงต้องปล่อยผมจะ
เฮ้ยเอาอยู่แล้วเหรอ
นักเรียนอย่าตกใจนะคะเวลาคุยอีกปล่อยผมจะ
วิ่งผมน้อยลงแล้วนะอายุมากขึ้น
[เพลง]
หนูอีก
ผมหยิก
เป็น Lion  King แล้วเนี่ย
สวยๆผู้หญิงสวยคือชีวิตหญิงจะเป็นแบบนี้
เดี๋ยวคุยแต่ก็มีกัน
คงโดน
ผมกู้หญิงเขาจะเป็นแบบนี้ค่ะนักเรียนคะ
ครับผมคู่หญิงใช่ไหม
หือ
ครับเวลายาวๆนะ
เป็นเธอไมโอนี่เลยนะคะ
ตาเด็ดๆแต่ถ้าผมแบบเนี้ยผมแล้วก็
อันนี้อยากโศกงั้นครูหญิงเนี่ยผมหยิก
ถ้าแบบนี้ผมตรงผมตรงอ่ะอยากสบมากๆก็ได้นะ
ผู้หญิงอะไรเด็กแล้วกันสั้นๆนะคะผู้หญิง
เนี่ยผมยี่เหมือนพ่อค่ะขอโทษ
ผู้หญิงผมหยิกเหมือนพ่อนะคะอยู่มาอะก็คุย
ลบกันดีกว่าอีกแล้วครูเอ๋มีอะไรอีกเหมือน
พ่อเนาะเอาเหมือนพ่อเหมือนพ่อเหมือนแม่
กูอ่ะพูดมาแล้วบอกเหมือนใครก็ได้ค่ะ
ครูเอ๋มีเหมือนจมูกจมูก
จมูกครูเอ๋เนี่ยเหมือนพ่อ
ใช่เพราะว่าคุณแม่กูเอ๋จะผูกสวยคุณแม่
จมูกเล็กๆแล้วก็ได้ท้ายทำไมคุยหญิงก็ไม่
ได้หรออ่าตัวเองเนี่ยจะจมูกเหมือน
พ่ออ้าววิ่งใช่ไม่ใช่นะแล้วครูเอกก็มีมี
อีกเอาเหมือนพ่อนะค่ะมีอีกอ่ะเอาของผู้
หญิงก่อนดีกว่าอ้าวของผู้หญิงใครผู้หญิง
ว่าจมูกครูผู้หญิงเหมือนแม่แต่วันแม่
แต่กูเอกตรงเนี้ยปีกจมูกตรงนี้ค่ะ
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าเหมือนพ่อมันๆ
แล้วผู้หญิงหันข้างนะคะหันข้างได้เลย
เดี๋ยวๆหันค่าเอาแว่นตาออกได้ไหมคะแต่ผู้
หญิงหันเอียงมาทางซ้ายนิดนึงนะอ่า
โอเคค่ะเหมือนหน้าจะเหมือนแม่นะเหมือนแม่
จมูกแหละทั้งหมดเลยร้อยเปอร์เซ็นต์เนี่ย
เหมือนแม่แต่แค่คิดตรงนี้บานเนี่ยเหมือน
พ่อ
ยิ้มเอ๋เอ๋
มีอะไรอีกร้อยเปอร์เซ็นถ้าเหมือนพ่อก่อน
แล้วกันครูเอ๋มีปากเนี่ยค่ะ
ปากเนี่ยเหมือนพ่อแน่ริมฝีปาก
หมอฟัน
เหมือนพ่อ
[เพลง]
พ่อแม่ครูเอ๋ริมฝีปากเล็ก
ฟันเล็ก
ผู้หญิงปากก็เหมือนแม่นะ
ไม่รู้อ่ะ
ผู้หญิงรู้ว่ากูหญิงมีหนึ่งอย่างเหมือน
พ่อครูเอ๋ปากผู้หญิงหรอจริงๆแบบผู้หญิง
ที่เนี่ยริมฝีปากหนักเหมือนพ่อที่มาตรง
นี้เนาะใต้เหมือนเหมือนพ่อกับแม่รวมกัน
ค่ะทรายแตกฟันน่ะ
ฟันเนี่ยเหมือนปุ๋ยอ้าวตัวเองเห
รอทำไมคะปะเนี่ยเหมือนคุณตาเลย
คุณครูหญิงคิดว่ากูหญิงฟันเหมือนพ่อ
พ่อฟันเหมือนกันเธอฟันใหญ่ๆเนี้ยค่ะก็คุณ
ตาก็ฟันใหญ่ๆ
เฮ้ยใหญ่อาจจะได้จากคุณตาแล้วก็คุณพ่อก็
เลยเป็นคนฟันใหญ่
ฟันใหญ่นะคะอะก็มีคนบอกบางคนก็พูดฟันครู
หญิงฟันครูเอ๋ดูแล้วเหมือนกัน
ทรายคือคุยจะบอกว่ามีคนบอกว่าครูหญิงเอา
ผู้หญิงอยู่นี่นะคะครูหญิงเนี่ยครูเอ๋
เหมือนกันเนี่ยตรงช่วงนี้ไงถ้าที่นี่ตรง
ปากนะก็เวลายิ้มน่าแล้วก็ฝันนะคะ
เราแน่ผู้หญิงอ่ะนะอย่างน่าคู๋เหมือนพ่อ
แต่ถ้าครูหญิงเหมือนใครเหมือนแม่เหมือน
แม่ก็แม่ก็น่าน่าจะมีนี้
เหมือนพ่อไหมเหมือนเหมือนๆ
มาๆ
ทำไม
มีนักเรียนมากๆบอกครูหญิงกับครูเอ๋เอ๋
หน้าเหมือนกัน
เมื่อก่อนใช่เมื่อก่อนนักเรียนมาแล้วนัก
เรียนเห็นครูหญิงอา
ว่าก่อนที่โรงเรียนใช่ไหมครูเอ๋น่ะ
1993 ใช่ไหมคะอ่าไปทำงานเป็นครู
ผู้หญิงปีอะไรคะ
2010  2007  2007 คะแล้วก็ 2007
แต่ถ้า 2007 คู่หญิงมาเป็นครูนะคะ
1919  6  1997
1997 ล่ะมีวีดีโอครูเอ๋ที่ YouTube
นอนนะคะเปลี่ยนเนี่ย
เราเข้าเจ็บเลยหรอประมาณหูเอ้า 7998
ประมาณเนี้ยคุยไม่แน่ใจมาแล้วประมาณ 1997
1998 หรือ 2,000 ประมาณนี้นะคะคือประมาณ
ประมาณประมาณคู๋คู๋จำไม่ได้ไม่เกินตี
2,000 บาท
นะคะแต่ไม่ใช่ชาแนลที่นี่ใช่ Channel อ๋อ
อ่า
ก็มีวีดีโอครูเอ๋เขามีนักเรียนมาแล้วนัก
เรียนเมื่อปี 2000  2000 ประกัน 2011
เนาะถ้าเสียชายค่ะนักเรียนมาแล้วก็ดูแล้ว
ก็
ประวัติสวัสดีครูเอ๋แต่ก็จะพูดกับผู้หญิง
ใช่ไหมกูเองอ่ะนั่งอ่านหนังสือขอนักเรียน
เดินมาแล้วก็หาผู้หญิงทรายสวัสดีครูเอ๋
แต่พูดกับครูหญิง
เอกก็หันครูเอ๋ที่นี่ค่ะ
ใช่ค่ะมีนักเรียน 1 คนผู้หญิงใช่ไหมคะครู
เอ๋ค่ะเขาเนี่ยเดินมาหาครูหญิงแล้วก็บอก
ว่าโอ้โอ๋ฉันดูวีดีโอคุณที่ YouTube ชอบ
มากๆคุย
ไม่มีเออกูเองกูเองไงอ่ะ
อาโกสตอรี่ผี
มีนักเรียนบ่ไม่มีเขาก็แบบโอ้ฉันชอบคุณ
ที่บ่อ๋อไม่ใช่ครูหญิงครูเอ๋
หวัดดีค่ะครูเอ๋ค่ะครูหญิงครูเอ๋
ryo เนี่ยมีนักเรียนมากๆบอกครูหญิงครู
เอ๋เอ๋หน้าเหมือนกันเพราะว่าคนอเมริกาคน
ยุโรปคน
คนต่างประเทศดูผู้หญิงดูครูเอ๋คิดว่า
เหมือนกันคู่เอกก็ต้องเปิดหน้าผากไม่
เหมือนกันค่ะไม่เหมือนสะดือผู้หญิงเสียมี
หน้าผากนิดหน่อยครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋มีอะไรเหมือน
พ่ออีกไหมคะ
มีอันนี้ค่ะคู่หญิงคู่เอ๋มีคิวข้างขวาอ่ะ
อีก
ครั้งที่หัวขวาเนี่ยเหมือนพ่อ
แล้วอิ่มข้างซ้ายเหมือนใครอยู่ข้างซ้าย
เหมือนแม่กินดีนะคะ
จริงจริงๆข้างเนี้ยพ่อข้างเดี๋ยวแม่มี
ทำไมไม่เหมือนพ่อสองข้างไม่รู้พ่อคิวแบบ
ได้เห็นมั้ยคิดวันนี้ใหญ่ๆค่ะใช่คิวข้าง
ขวาใหญ่ๆคิวข้างนี้คู๋เนี่ยมีเล็กๆนิด
หน่อยแล้วก็สั้นๆได้อันเนี้ยแม่เนี้ยพ่อ
[เพลง]
นักครูเอกหน้าน่ะทั้งหมดเนี่ยเหมือนพ่อ
กับผิว
ผิวสีขาวเก๋สีสี
มีสีเขาขาวๆเนี่ยเหมือน
อุ้ยทำไมคุยลบ
อ่ะผิวครูเอ๋เอ๋ผิวขาวเหมือนใครคะเหมือน
แม่มันแม่อ๋อเหมือนแม่เหมือนแม่ผิวขาว
เหมือนแม่แต่คิดว่าน่าคู๋น่ะ 90%
เหมือนใครเหมือนพ่อ
อาผู้หญิงนะคะมีอะไรเหมือนพ่ออีกคิ้ว
เหมือนใครคะ
คิดว่าคิ้วเหมือนแม่ไปค่ะแต่ครูหญิงเนี่ย
มี
ขนหนูได้เลยจะเห็นหรือเปล่าอ่ะคะ
นักเรียนไม่เห็น
มีมีขน
ก็มีมีผมและมีผมที่มีผมออกมาค่ะมีหนวด
เนี่ยเราเห็นในเขียวเขียวๆอ่ะพี่ขนไม่ไม่
เหมือนพ่อง้อเหมือนพี่เอ๋วาดขาครูหญิง
ได้ไหมคะอ๋อได้ๆเดี๋ยวกูอีกว่ากูหญิงให้
ได้คะเดี๋ยวนะคะนักเรียนสืบตื่นๆๆๆ
[เพลง]
แม่แม่ๆหายอีกละอันนี้ครูหญิง
หน้าครูหญิงอะไรมัดผมไปวัดใหม่ได้ไหมกู
ยังไม่ชอบได้ค่ะได้ๆค่ะพี่อยากว่าใหม่ลบ
ใหม่ทำไมว่าน่าเกลียดจังเลยค่ะ
รู้นิผู้หญิงนะคะพี่เอ๋มีคิวแบบนี้หิว
สั้นหากท่านไม่ตาเล็กๆ
ง่าปัดกระโปรง
เอาชัยค่ะ
แขนขา
ๆน่ารักจังเลย
นี่ล่ะขนขาผู้หญิงมีขนขาเยอะมากเหมือนพ่อ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
รู๋คะครูหญิงกับน้องชายคนคนที่ 1 ต่อคน
นี้ๆค่ะคนนี้เนี่ยมีขนเยอะเหมือนพ่อขอ
ครูเอ๋เนี่ยไม่มีขน
ไม่
แม่ครูหญิงไม่มีขน
แม่ครูเอ๋เอ๋แม่ครูเอ๋เอ๋ก็ไม่มีขนคืออ่ะ
น่ารักและขอโทษนะคะนักเรียน
ขอโทษ
รักแร้ของคุณแม่ครูเอ๋อ่ะ
รักแร้เนี่ยรักและธรรมดารักและคนอ่ะ
มันต้องมีขนใช่ไหมค่ะใช่ค่ะขนรักแร้แม่
ครูเอ๋
ไม่มี
แม่ที่สองก็ไม่มีนี่เอ๋
ก็ไม่มีนี้วันนี้กูเองไอ้เอ๋หมือนแม่ใช่
ไหมคะอันนี้จะแม่ขอโทษนะคะขอโทษนักเรียน
เมื่อไหร่คะสนใจไม่มีขนค่ะไม่มีขนที่แขน
ไม่มีขนรักแร้ๆเหมือนคุณแม่ผู้หญิงเนี่ย
มีขนขนเนียนนิ้วก็มีขนนะคะจะคุยจะมองไม่
ค่อยเห็นนิ้วก็ไม่มีขนใช่ค่ะมีขนมากๆ
เหมือนพ่อไม่เหมือนพ่อผู้หญิงก็ไม่เหมือน
ครูเอ๋เนาะในเหมือนค่ะครูเอ๋ไม่มีขนครู
เอ๋แล้วครูหญิงเนี่ยผิวผิวอะไรคะ
ผิวไม่ขาวเนี่ยเหมือนใครคะเออไม่เปลี่ยน
ตา
ๆนี่ๆอ่ะอันนี้พ่อครูเอ๋ใช่ไหมคะนักเรียน
พ่อครูเอ๋ตาคู่หญิงแล้วก็พ่อก็มีอันนี้
ปู่คู๋ค่ะ
แล้วก็หญ้า
พ่อของพ่อครูเอ๋น่ะสีขาวอ๋อแม่ของพ่อครู
เอ๋สี
ช็อคโกแลตสมีสีน้ำตาลผิวเข้มในผิวเข้ม
คุณพ่อพ่อกูเอกก็เอารวมกัน
ร้อน 4 น้ำตาลน้ำตาลแบบนี้อะป้ายผู้หญิง
ก็เลยผิวเนี่ยเหมือนคุณตา
เหมือนคุณยายเหมือนคุณทวดคุณทวดใส่กะกว่า
นี้คนนี้ก็เนี่ยจ่ายคุณทวดเหมือนคุณถ้วย
นิดหน่อยเพราะคุณพ่อกูหญิงผิวเหมือนครู
เอ๋
[เพลง]
ขอโทษค่ะ I ถ่ายเพราะว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยน้อง
ชายน้องชายเนี่ยผิวขาวกว่าครูหญิง
น้องชาย 2 คนผิวขาวเหมือน
แม่สมัยคะใส่ค่ะเหมือนแม่คุณยายมาหาโอ้
โห้ผู้หญิงก็เพราะว่าคุณพ่อกูหญิงผิวขาว
คุณตาไอ้คุณปู่ครูหญิงก็ผิวขาว
คุณย่าก็เขาขาวๆก็มีนี่ล่ะค่ะนี่คุณตาครู
หญิงเนี่ยอ่ะที่ผิวสีน้ำตาลใช่ไหมคุณตา
ผิวสี
คนไทยบอกดำแดงนี่ผิวเข้มใช่ไหมครับผิว
เข้มไม่ขาวไม่หายขาวนี่มี
มีอะไรอีกผู้หญิงโทรหา
สูง
เหมือนหลายรูปสิงห์ตีเรียกไอ้ไม่สูง
อ้าว
คลิงเตี้ยเหมือนในคะเหมือนแม่ค่ะ
เตี้ยเหมือนขอแก้ร้านขายพ่อเนี่ยสูงค่ะ
แม่เบี้ยผู้หญิงแหละเตี้ยเหมือนแม่ครูเอ๋
ล่ะคะ OA ก็ตีอ่ะเหมือนแม่
งูคุณพ่อก็สูงกว่า
ถ่ายเตี้ยกว่า
เทียบเหมือนแม่แปลว่าอะไรขาคู๋ผู้หญิงขา
หาทำไมหาคู๋เหมือนแม่
เฮ้อขาเล็กๆหรอคะ
ขาเละไหมเดี๋ยวกูเห็นลบอันนี้ก่อนขา
ขาแบบนี้
[เพลง]
ค่ะคุณแม่ขาขาแบบนี้
น้ออ้าย
โป้ขาแบบนี้พ่อขาแบบนี้พ่อจะตรงๆอ๋ออ๋อ
ครูเอ๋ขาไม่ตรงเหมือนแม่เนี่ยเหรอคะ
อ๋อ
เหมือนคุณแม่อันนี้ครูหญิงไม่รู้ขอบคุณ
ผู้หญิงไม่ไม่เคยเหมาะดูใช่มั้ยไม่ดูไม่
ดูใช่ดูขาเหมือนใครนะคะมีอีกค่ะมีเอกมี
อะไรอีกคะเล็บเล็บเล็บตีนอ๋อเด็ดเล็บครู
เอ๋เอ๋เหมือนพ่อหนู
ครูหญิงหรอคุณพ่อพ่อพ่อแม่ผู้หญิงน้องชาย
น้องชายเล็บเหมือนกันน่ะกูเองฮ่าๆเหมือน
กับพ่อกูหญิงกับพ่อครูเอ๋นะเล็บก็เหมือน
กันที่ละเล็บอย่างนี้ค่ะนักเรียนๆเล็ก
เหมือนกันแล้วก็พี่สาวครูเอ๋เอ๋ก็เล็บ
เหมือนกัน
ใช่มะเพราะอ่าออกพี่สาวอันนี้พี่สาวใช่
ไหมคะพี่สาวนิครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋อยู่ที่นี่
พี่เขยนะคะพี่สาวพี่เขยพ่อเอ๋พอหญิงนะคะ
แล้วก็พ่อเอ๋เล็บเหมือนกันอีกแป้งครูหญิง
ผู้หญิงน้องชาย
ครูหญิงน้องทรายน้องทรายคุณแม่คุณพ่อเล็บ
เหมือนกันค่ะเล็บเล็บสระยาวเล็บสระยาว
เล็บณเดชน์ค่ะ
เนาะครูเอ๋ใช่ครูเอ๋อ่าอันนี้เหมือนพ่อ vs
ลืมน้ำนะคะตื่นหนาวจ่ายคะแต่ครูเอ๋ตอนนี้
เข้าไอเหมือนพ่อ
ครูเอ๋ไม่เป็นไรครู AI ได้ว่าตอนนี้เนี่ย
มันหมดเวลาแล้วแล้วหรอคะชายก็นักเรียน
เนาะนักเรียนเนี่ยเหมือนพ่อก็หรือหรือ
เหมือนแม่มากกว่าเกาะ comment ได้เนาะว่า
ครูเอ๋เนี่ยเหมือนพ่อ
มากกว่าแม่เงินผู้หญิงก็พ่อแม่รวมกันนะ
ไก่รักเรียนคิดว่าครูหญิงครูเอ๋เหมือนกัน
ไหมก็โอเค
เหมือนกันเหมือนนะคะ
บีไม่เหมือนกันนะ
อาเกาะคอมเม้นท์บอกได้ค่ะหายส่วนวีดีโอ
นี้ครูหญิงกับครูเอ๋ต้องไปแล้วนะคะผู้
หญิงก็คุยมองกล้องดูให้นักเรียนดูว่า
เหมือนกันไหมพิมพ์
หยุดยิ้ม
อยู่ทีมจะไม่เหมือนนะคะนักเรียนคอมเม้น
ได้นะว่าครูหญิงครูเอ๋เนี่ยเบื่อเหมือน
กันหรือไม่เหมือนกันบางคนบอกเสียงที่พูด
น่ะเสียงสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะชื่ออะไรคะ
ชื่อเอกค่ะ
เสียงเหมือนกันใช่เสียงเหมือนกันไหมไม่
เหมือนผู้หญิงอ่ะสวัสดีค่ะเวลามีโทรศัพท์
ไงโทรศัพท์
เวลามีโทรศัพท์ฮัลโหลสวัสดีค่ะวันนี้บอก
ครูเอ๋หรอหมอเขาบอกว่าเสียงเหมือนกันง่าย
นักเรียนคิดว่าเหมือนกันหรือสิเหมือนกัน
คอมเม้นได้นะคะถ้าขาดแล้วพบกันใหม่คลิป
หน้าค่ะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะไปวะ